I just got to say these costumes are
kind of perfect we are the ultimate DC
dude
yes told me everything about today's
episode of TC laughs all right I'll do
it we're gonna talk with Jeff Parker
about taking over Aquaman then we've got
mark and Draco we're gonna talk about
Paris also Batman origin DLC what about
the Comic Con giveaway okay I can't
really understanding what are you
talking your Batman voice it's not a bad
event voice maybe offer me a lozenge do
you want a sausage tons of fan
speculation on the internet about the
new dlc specifically a guy who's very
cold-hearted yes he is everybody talked
about Mr Freeze and you are here to talk
about the fact that Mr Freeze is the
focus right it's cold cold heart which
is our big open world narrative based
DLC that we'll be releasing for Arkham
origins
we're super-excited to kind of give fans
the origin of this great Batman
character it's like a mini chapter in
the game you know if you guys played and
saw an initiation it was more like a
challenge map that had a little
narrative wrapped around it this is
actually you know in-game mission story
content with a you know brand-new story
wrapped around Mr Freeze in the arkham
origins setting and you know batman is a
man who's got a lot of wonderful toys
yes and you're presenting him with some
new toys for this particular challenge
yep so early in the dlc batman will take
on mr. freeze's guys who have cryogenic
weaponry the Batman is experiencing
facing for the first time and he comes
to realize very quickly that the current
suit he has is not good enough so he
tries this experimental suit that alpha
has been working on which we're calling
the XE which is so for extreme
conditions that will actually change
gameplay and help you be more resilient
against these type of weapons and when
Scott Schneider drops that suit into one
of his books your hearts gonna explode
I love it I love Scott so if he wants to
use our suit we'd be more than alright
go for it and it's not just about the
DLC today you actually brought something
very special for the fans for your
viewers of DC all-access we brought a
collector's edition of the game signed
by mr. Troy Baker who's our Joker if you
guys want a chance to win just tweet us
your favorite Arkham game using the
hashtag DC all-access but thank you guys
so much for being so my pleasure so as
always I think I speak for all of them
when I say keep making awesome DLC we
will this story arc of fairest we're
taking Cinderella to India what was it
about that setting that you were like
yes this is the perfect place for her
well because the arc though deals a lot
with those most hybrid Mouse creatures I
was always fascinated by this temple in
India worships rats and like the guy
that sits there will sit there and
they'll be millions of rats crawling
over their big bowls of milk everywhere
and they went to India the second or
third arc of Pharaoh state but they
hadn't touched on Ramayan rami owns this
big hulking hot glue gun I'm like of
course Cinderella would know mmm so what
I love about your writing is that you
write such badass women and for
Cinderella she's a spy what kind of spy
would you equate her too oh she's
definitely the actual novel Ian Fleming
James Bond you know she does what she
has to do and she's not afraid to use
Pat Benatar
as a weapon I think women would be
better spies than men so you know we can
use our feminine wiles
absolutely how did you come about
working on this project I've known bill
for years I've been a fan of Bill's
since he used to draw Dungeons & Dragons
ads in the back of comics in the 80s he
said that there was an opening on the
third Cinderella arc he said you have
any ideas and I said well whatever
happened to those mice that turned what
if one of them didn't turn into back
into a man when this clock struck
midnight and from there the idea just
extrapolated to tie in to what's going
on in the main book so and then it's all
gonna come to a head and Fabletown an
issue 26 so it's going to get it's gonna
get pretty crazy
Aquaman without question one of the most
talked-about books from the new 52 what
was it like stepping into the shoes of a
little writer named Jeff Jones when Jeff
and Ivan started the book it they took
it back to 50s 60s Aquaman and just
started working out that with a modern
sensibility and that worked completely
for me so that's where I'm going with it
but a lot of it is I wanted to get
Aquaman back up on the surface I really
do feel like people lose interest when
he spends too much time underwater but
that's important and it needs to be
there but I think you've got to actually
work it out to almost a proportionate
high balance you know what is your
collaboration with Paul the artist
what's that process like it's like
here's what I'm thinking of doing what
kind of stuff were you hoping to get to
one of the things he put in for a while
back was he wanted to draw a Swamp Thing
all right we can do that we can have
Swamp Thing appear in Aquaman that's no
problem so an issue 31 it's all him and
Swamp Thing but like coming up in the
next issue he has to go to his high
school reunion and that's something that
not every superhero artists is
necessarily good at it's like how do you
get that across that so everybody who's
been going through this are they gonna
be able to relate to this and I think
you will in fact I'm extremely proud of
the whole scene when he goes to his high
school hey there
I'm Judd Myers from blast-off comics
well some heroes say they're here to
help are they really
or do they have more sinister motives
only a man of Lex Luthor's intellect can
really know for sure so imagine you're
the smartest man on earth a self-made
billionaire everyone loves you then
along comes an all-powerful alien who
can do pretty much anything a God on
earth
and the people are just supposed to
trust him I don't think so
enlisted by the government early in
Superman's career to trap and study the
Man of Steel Luthor's obsession with
proving Superman to be an alien threat
eventually led to his downfall
public disgrace and being jailed for his
role in creating Kryptonian monsters and
viruses based on Superman's DNA Luthor
and his rivalry with the Blue Boy Scout
has taken on many incarnations since his
first appearance in Action Comics number
23 in 1940 from mad scientist to cunning
businessman to mech suit in mania these
days the new 52 Luthor leads the
injustice league against the conquering
crime syndicate and in April the
unthinkable will happen Lex Luthor will
be joining the Justice League and the
lead meeting has just got a lot more
awkward I'm Jud meyers see you next time
she's feeling a lot better right now
this Superman thing really suits me yeah
I mean you're really getting your color
back Blair you're gonna need to practice
that Batman voice okay I think you gave
me your cold okay offer you a lozenge
yeah
kidding great news you guys you can
still come to comic-con with us yes all
you need to do is go to DC Comics comm
slash watch and win click right down
here answer three trivia questions
correctly for your chance to win four
day passes to comic-con oh and airfare
vouchers and hotel rooms we are hooking
you up with our producer Bridget also or
if you're into it our producer Chuck